what are storm brew Fox acid and
shifting shadow are they rejected titles
for b-movie Bond sequels you asked close
they are in fact just a handful of the
NSA spying programs a sampling of a
complex surveillance web that has its
eyes and ears on all of us with billions
of dollars behind it the agency's reach
extends well beyond the borders of the
u.s. it has more than just a global
footprint it is more like a global bear
track of a really big bear why does it
matter here's how Julien York of the
Electronic Frontier Foundation put it
when you realize that you're being
surveilled by such a world power you
tend to change the way you talk and the
things that you talk about publicly or
privately by surveilling you know the
whole world unmask the NSA is creating
an environment of self-censorship
and while the NSA claims its goal is to
monitor possible terrorist activity the
documents leaked by Edward Snowden
revealed that much of the surveillance
has little to do with terrorism and more
to do with broad information gathering
everything from personal phone calls of
presidents to a country's financial
interests as it turns out some of the
countries the NSA targets most are also
the u.s. s closest allies India Japan
Mexico South Korea Turkey and even NATO
and EU allies like France and Italy
German Chancellor Angela Merkel's phone
was tapped for years while Brazilian
President Dilma Rousseff was so angry
the u.s. spied on her and the state-run
oil company Petrobras that she demanded
a public apology and called off a White
House visit but it's not just world
leaders who are target's ordinary people
are - everyone has reason to be
concerned but not only that they're
being monitored but that the things that
they say could be used against them at
some point and it's not just emails and
phone calls that have been mined the NSA
has also collected credit card numbers
and monitored Internet users cookies
data used by advertisers on sites like
Google and Facebook and now that you
know how you're being spied on you
my task what can I do about it you can
disable cookies to web browse tribally
or you can use free software like tor
which hides your IP address you can make
secure phone calls using applications
like red phone or silent circle which
encrypt your conversations or you can
chat online with OTR software that keeps
all those emoticons off-the-record but
keep in mind encryption services aren't
always perfect and some are even
designed to be hackable by law
enforcement how are you feeling
surveilled worried indifferent let us
know your thoughts on the NSA's global
reach and whatever you're thinking
hopefully by now it's more informed this
has been cheat sheet on aj+
share and spread the knowledge
you